the queue data structure is a way to
hold data it's similar to a stack while
a stack is first in last out a queue is
first in first out an example in real
life is when you are waiting in line to
buy something at a store the first
person to get in the line is the first
person to get to the cash register
another example is a print queue when a
lot of people are printing documents at
the same printer the documents are
printed in the order they were sent to
the print queue in JavaScript just like
a stack you can implement a queue with
just an array if you want to limit an
array to just the traditional queue
methods you must create it yourself let
me show you one such implementation so
we have the queue right here and we're
going to have a collection that's going
to collect all the items in the queue
and this is just kind of a helper
function to print or to cancel that log
the collection and here that the main
main methods of a queue we have in queue
which is going to push the first item on
to the queue and then we have DQ which
is going to take an item off the queue
so there's two ways to do it with an
array items can go into the array at the
beginning of the array or items can go
in the array at the end of the array in
this implementation items are going into
the array at the end of the array and
then they come off of the array at the
beginning of the array to put an item
onto the queue we're just going to push
that item that element onto the queue
then to DQ we're going to use the rage
IFFT dot shift just pulls off the first
item of the array it removes the first
item of the array and returns it another
queue method is front this is just going
to return what item is at the front of
the array without removing the item off
of the array so we're just going to do
collection effort just going to return
what items at the at the zero index of
the collection array and size we just
try to figure out the size of the queue
pretty straightforward just collection
that length and then is empty check if
it's empty
if there's not no items on the queue so
let's see how that is going to work
down here I'm just going to uncomment
that and run the code so are we in queue
we create a new queue then we Inc we
include ABC so the line the end of the
line is the end of the array the
beginning of the line is the beginning
of the array so it's going to print a B
C here and then D Q means that the item
at the beginning of the array is going
to be removed so the a is going to be
removed
and then we're going to do Q dot front
which I forgot to put that console.log
here if I run that again you'll see that
it's going to check what what elements
at the front of the array which is B and
I'm going to print the array again it's
just me B and C because we DQ'd a
another way to create a queue is a
priority queue and a priority queue not
only do you pass the element into the
queue you also pass the priority of the
element so if all the priorities are the
same number it's going to behave just
like a normal queue but when you pass in
elements at different priorities the
elements that are passed in with a
higher priority are sent to the
beginning of the queue so all elements
with priority 5 are ahead of elements
with priority 4 but if elements have the
same priority it just behaves like a
normal Q so let me explain how the
priority queue works first let me show
you an example of this code down here
where we're using the priority queue so
then create the priority queue and then
we're going to in queue something and so
we're going to pass in an array the
first element in the array is the item
we want to put on to the priority queue
the second thing in the array is the
priority so you can see I'm not pushing
them on in the same order to 3-1 but if
I run this when we the print the
collection it's going to print in the
order of the priority and just to show
another example let me add an item with
the same priority as an item we already
and if I run that you can see these two
items have the same priority so they're
in the queue in the order that they were
pushed on to the queue so everything's
the same on a priority queue except the
in queue function so in the NQ function
first we're going to check if the queue
is empty if it's empty you're just going
to push on the element but if it's not
empty you're going to have to check the
priorities to see where to put the
element on so we're going to create a
variable just to check whether we've
added the item to the queue or not and
it would fall it starts at false and now
we're going to have to run through each
element in the the collection or the
queue to check what the priorities are
so we have this floor loop it's going to
run through each item in the collection
and we're going to check is the element
at index one remember the element that
we pass into the queue is an array index
zero is the item you want to put into
the queue and index one is the priority
so is the priority of the element we're
passing into the queue less than the
priority of the item in the collection
that we're checking and see we're using
this eye from the for loop we're going
to go through and check every item in
the collection and we're going to check
the index 1 which is the priority of
that item and then if the priority is
less than the item we're going to add
that item or the element to the
collection array that's what the splice
is doing and then we're going to say add
it equals true we're going to break out
of the loop here and then we're going to
be done except if the element hasn't
been added we are going to then push the
element to the array and the only thing
that's slightly different is this DQ
method and this the way I did is kind of
optional you could return the entire
element with the item and the priority
or you can do an idea where I just
returned the item without the priority
here
that's just index 0 of this value which
is the the items that we got off the
beginning of the array well those are
cues and priority queues thanks for
watching don't forget to subscribe
and remember use your code for good